und wir müssen hier in dieser Sendung
unbedingt auch über eine Frau sprechen
die hat nämlich das gemacht was ich die
Mannschaft was ich Manuel Neuer nicht
getraut hat die One Love Binder hat sie
nämlich getragen die Innenministerin
Nancy fazer schauen wir uns das Foto
nämlich einmal an sie war in Katar im
Stadion da hat sich die Binde angezogen
hat sich also das getraut was ich die
Männer dann nicht getraut haben Frau
Keller das ist so ein bisschen ihr Thema
aber ich seh schon mit den Augen also
dafür nicht von ihnen nehme doch einen
für gratismut
für gratis Mut auf der Tribüne weil es
ja auch überhaupt nichts kostet und weil
man nur versucht in irgendeiner Form
jetzt sozusagen Haltung zu zeigen wo es
überhaupt nicht schwer ist weil
natürlich niemand irgendwie nennt sie
Faser verhaftet oder sonst irgendwas ihr
antut aber in der Tat ähm es nervt
eigentlich nur noch und deswegen
plädiere ich massiv dafür dass wir
endlich die Politik aus den Stadien
rauswerfen und zwar nicht nur das Thema
jetzt Regenbogen fahren abendbinden oder
sonst was sondern
ist früher hat man sich in einem
Fußballstadion nur hingekniet um seine
offenen Schnürsenkel zu binden und heute
muss man ein Statement dafür abgeben die
ganze Sache ist sowieso verlogen weil
wir natürlich wenn es um Gas oder Öl
geht aus Katar dann buckelt selbst unser
Wirtschaftsminister gerne auf den Fotos
aber jetzt verlangen wir von der
Fußballnationalmannschaft dass sie
Haltung zeigt gleichzeitig habe ich
keinen Mitleid mit ihnen weil natürlich
jede Frau im Iran die ohne Kopftuch auf
die Straße geht mehr Eier hat mit
Verlaub als die gesamte deutsche
Nationalmannschaft insofern sollten wir
einfach den die Sache wieder auf die
Füße stellen und sagen werft den Sport
raus aber dann bitte auch keine Klima
Bekenntnisse bei der Formel 1 und keine
black lives matter Knie Fälle und so
weiter sondern lasst uns Fußball spielen
wir haben hier eine WM zu gewinnen und
deswegen würde ich vorschlagen es sollte
mal alle auf dem Platz finden und Tore
schießen
das ist vor allem wichtiger Hinweis nach
dem Spiel ich hoffe das Spiel gegen
Japan will Anna haben wir so ein
bisschen stimmen Sie zu
Politik muss rausnehmen nicht gelingen
weil das Politik ist ja massiv in
Stadien drin das gibt einmal durch den
DFB der da sehr verunglückt glaube ich
diese ganze Aktion gesteuert hat das war
ein richtiger rohrgebirer den wir erlebt
haben aber natürlich bei den Ultras die
ja in allen Stadien der Bundesliga sind
sind die Ultra sehr sehr mächtig
geworden sie sind politisch sie sind
politisiert und das ist ein Frau mal
Wunsch aber man wird es nicht nicht
erreichen die Frage ist hier ob die
Mannschaft wirklich gut beraten bei sich
so zu engagieren oder ob nicht der DFB
hier mehr hätte machen können und die
Mannschaft etwas abschotten können
Menschenrechte so im Vorfeld ebenso halb
im Grunde einzubringen und dann dieses
Drama um die Kapitänsbinde da kann man
sich ich weiß das ist nicht sehr populär
das zu sagen aber ich glaube wirklich
als Supersportler die sich mit den
Supersport dann Mist was diese Welt
besten Mannschaften ja tun unabhängig
von diesen Temperaturwechsel um plus 20
Grad die wieder zu erleiden haben da
muss man sich auch kontrazentrieren
fokussieren und nicht überlegen wie
wahrscheinlich bis kurz vor dem Spiel
mit welcher Geste gehe ich jetzt da
drauf so schlecht gespielt weil sie sich
darauf konzentriert haben weil die sich
nicht auf dem Fußball konzentriert haben
sondern davor überlegen mussten welches
Statement welches Zeichen setzen wir
jetzt und eben ganz viel Aufregungen
dann war vor dem Foto keine Abwehr die
waren sicherlich nicht nur dadurch
bedingt sondern die haben Sie auch schon
vorher und die waren vorher sichtbar
aber
sowas lenkt natürlich ab und man braucht
volle Fokussierung bei solchen Sachen
und es waren so viele Unwegbarkeiten ist
Drama um die Binde sicherlich haben die
bis heute kurz vor dem Spiel nachgedacht
mit welcher Geste gehen wir denn dahin
Nachrichten aus der Heimat die Sponsoren
melden sich und sonst was er das hätte
man eigentlich ein bisschen fernhalten
müssen von den Spielern aber diese ganze
Debatte ist ja eigentlich auch verlogen
insofern weil das hat man ja alles
gewusst ja also man hat ja diese
Fußball-WM verschärfelt schon vor über
10 Jahren an einen wüsten statt ohne
Fußballtradition ich möchte gar nicht
wissen wie viel Geld damals geflossen
ist damit man eben unter diesen aber
witzigen um Bedingungen auch sag mal von
den Temperaturen her in einem Wüstenland
das nicht größer ist als Hessen eine
Fußball-WM ausrichtet wo man die Fans
auch noch einkaufen muss damit die Ränge
voll werden ja das sind einfach Dinge wo
man sagen muss jetzt plötzlich irgendwie
erregen sich alle auf und jetzt ist eine
Aufregung aber mit Verlaub diese
Entscheidung der FIFA ist schon vor über
einem Jahrzehnt gefallen man hatte jetzt
zehn Jahre Zeit sich aufzuregen und
jetzt irgendwie beeilen sich alle noch
schnell etwas gut zu machen obwohl man
zehn Jahre lang überhaupt kein Problem
damit hatte und das meine ich mit diesem
verlogen dass man sagt Leute und es ich
glaube auch dass die volle dass der
Sport sich keinen Gefallen tut damit
auch die Spieler nicht ja weil sie haben
jetzt vollmundig was versprochen und
jetzt müssen sie sich rechtfertigen
hätten sie gar nicht erst angefangen
sich quasi politisch zu positionieren
dann bräuchten sie jetzt auch nichts
zurücknehmen und ich glaube die meisten
Fans regen sich zumindest die vor Ort
mehr über das Alkoholverbot auch also
als über die Frage irgendwie welche
Armbinde jetzt wo getragen wird oder
nicht ja auch tatsächlich viel zu viele
Klischees die da reinkommen auch mit
Verlaub bei Ihnen jetzt klar
Katar ist auch eine Weltmeisterschaft
das ist die erste auf diesem arabischen
Kontinent klar ist es ein kleines Land
und sicherlich ist das nicht so wie das
unseren Standards unbedingt entspricht
aber ist ein Land das ich nach ausweist
der internationalen
Arbeitsrechtsorganisation
ILO vielen anderen in den letzten Jahren
doch massiv gewandelt hat und ich meine
bei uns war Homosexualität in
Deutschland 123 Jahre verboten ich kann
mir selber dran erinnern auch das wurde
erst in den in den in den Jahren von
Willy Brandt dann eben aufgehoben und
unter Gerhard Schröder gab es noch eine
weitere Liberalisierung es gibt doch
viele Menschen die sich haben verstecken
müssen frage sie mal hier in Spanien wie
das war als er im Münsterland als
Homosexueller Jugendliche aufgewachsen
ist und das ist auch noch nicht so lange
her also dahin zu gehen und so so so
massiv jetzt die die deutschen
Errungenschaften zu Preisen und jeden in
Abrede zu stellen der sich auf den Weg
macht das ist auch nicht richtig
übrigens
ich halte es übrigens für richtig ja
sozusagen eben dass man sagt man muss
das vorher entscheiden also man kann
auch nicht unsere Moralvorstellungen auf
dieses Land projizieren oder erwarten
dass Qatar jetzt sozusagen irgendwie
alle seine Prinzipien über Wort wirft
nur ich finde man hätte das zehn Jahre
vorher sozusagen entscheiden müssen
spielt das für uns eine Rolle oder
spielt es keine Rolle und vor zehn
Jahren hat man gesagt okay wir wissen
das alles wir nehmen das so hin dass
diese Gastgeber anders sind cool
anders ja so anders aber aber wie gesagt
diese Entscheidung ist doch vor zehn
Jahren gefällt worden dass man obwohl es
so ist trotzdem eine Fußball-WM dort
machen will und deswegen finde ich es
verlogen jetzt plötzlich so zu tun als
sei einem das jetzt erst aufgefallen das
will ich nur sagen grundsätzlich bin ich
da aber eigentlich bei Ihnen dass ich
sage wir können eigentlich gar nicht
erwarten sozusagen dass die dass wir
politische Themen jetzt auf dem
Fußballfeld oder im Stadion aus also ein
bisschen Einigkeit bei ihnen zweijährige
schauen sie sind Sie Fan haben sie sich
gedacht das ist doch mal ein Zeichen was
die Mannschaft ersetzt beim Foto hält
die Hand von dem Mund kein Fußballfan
aber ich gehe da mit der Frau Keller
gleich man sollte Politik Politik sein
lassen und Sport Sport denn das schadet
ja allem nur und wir haben ja momentan
sowieso meiner Meinung nach zumindest
eine relativ verlogene politische
Debatte
es wird ja nirgendwo mehr mit der
Wahrheit agiert es wird meinungspolitik
gemacht und ja wir müssen mal wieder
zurückkommen zu einer vernünftigen
Politik
also meine mein Eindruck ist der das so
seit 2015 eigentlich
viel öfter oder viel mehr Fußballer in
die politische Debatte eingegriffen
haben politische Statements abgegeben
haben einmal für Einwanderung dann war
die Geschichte im Stadion in München
damals auch schon mal mit der Armbinde
im Spiel gegen Ungarn übrigens habe ich
das Spiel in Ungarn gesehen in Ungarn
zusammen und ähm also das waren schon
höchst unglückliche Aktionen weil ich
denke schon der Fußball soll erstens
Sport sein und auf der anderen Seite ist
Fußball was wir dabei verkennen auch ein
Gemeinschaftserlebnis und was ich
momentan sehe bei mir draußen ich wohne
auf dem Dorf und da wohne ich auch sehr
gern
aber ich kann nicht so wie bei der
letzten EM oder der letzten WM so die
Begeisterung spüren was die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft betrifft ich
sehe auch nicht ich sehe auch keine
Autos die mit Deutschlandfahnen
herumfahren in meinem Umfeld was ich
früher wenn em war oder WM war viel mehr
gesehen haben
aber darauf zurückzukommen dennoch sind
die ja Vorbilder sie stehen in der
Öffentlichkeit die Sportler das kann man
sagen das war wie früher popstars geht
das das geht doch gar nicht ohne Politik
das geht doch gar nicht ohne dass man
diese Vorbildfunktion nutzt gerade in
diesen Zeiten das ist ja nicht eher so
dass man sie zuvor Bildern stilisiert
die sie gar nicht sein können und auch
nicht sein wollen es ist ja auch
kollektiv wird dass er jetzt auch
verlangt also ich habe mir die selber
die Frage gestellt was würde eigentlich
passieren wenn ähm manche Mitglieder
unserer Nationalmannschaft sagen sich
öffentlich dazu äußern dass sie sagen
wir hatten sowieso keinen Bock auf das
alles und ich bin übrigens auch anderer
Meinung wäre das überhaupt möglich ja
oder würden sie nicht eigentlich von
deutscher Seite völlig fertig gemacht
werden ja wir haben ja inzwischen ein
Klima wo man es ist kein Wunder dass
keine Deutschland fahren oder sonst
irgendwo was ist weil es wird ja nahezu
geächtet diese Fußball-WM überhaupt
anzuschauen ja sondern man redet
eigentlich nur darüber irgendwie ob es
nicht im moralisch Verwerfliches
überhaupt zu schauen wir haben ja ich
habe gerade heute habe ich gesehen
irgendwie ein WDR Moderator sagte
irgendwie das sei mit Hitler wenn man
wenn man die Fußball-WM schaut also wer
hat wir sind jetzt quasi schon beim
Hitler vergessen
dafür um hier sich dann auch noch
beschimpfen zu lassen das passt ja auch
nicht ganz zusammen die öffentlich
rechtlichen ausgegeben angeblich um die
Übertragungsrechte sich zu sichern und
jetzt kann ich mir jedes Mal wenn ich
ein Spiel Angehörige anhören wie blöd
ich bin mir das Spiel anzugucken also
dass ich da keinen Spaß habe das zu
gucken obwohl ich tolle Spiele schon
gesehen habe gestern das Spiel
Frankreich ich meine kann ich sagen ich
bin Frankreich nachdem
das war wunderbar
[Gelächter]
aber wie wichtig sind Vorbilder die
können ja auch die Gesellschaft
verändern die können ja auch zum
Nachdenken anregen verlangen wir dazu
viel von den Sportlern
ich glaube wir haben auf jeden Fall also
in Sportler muss ich konzentrieren
können auf seinen Sport natürlich hat er
auch darüber hinaus eine Funktion erst
Vorbild er ist Idol er ist er oder sie
natürlich auch und kann auch
gesellschaftliche Anstöße geben aber ich
meine Homosexualität im Fußball welcher
ich kann mir keiner erzählen dass unter
den aktiven Fußballern keiner schwul ist
ne da gibt es sicherlich 10 20 30 40 in
der Bundesliga die die wenn sie
rauskommen würden sagen würden ich bin
warum macht Sinn keine oder erst nach
Beendigung der Karriere
machen würde wie Jugendlichen würde man
noch Hoffnung geben
aber die Aufgabe des Fußballs ist es
nicht sozusagen irgendwie Homosexualität
zu promoten oder sozusagen das Thema zu
promoten
ist doch sind wenn nicht vielleicht
sogar schon viel weiter oder warum muss
sich eigentlich ein Fußballer outen
irgendwie also welches öffentliche
Interesse gibt es daran dass wir erst
nach Ende seiner wäre Angst hat dass er
sonst Probleme bekommt ist doch ganz
einfach
vorbild-rolle muss er denn nicht zur
allererst erstmal Vorbild in dem sein
was er macht Fußball spielen eben das
ist das ist doch der Punkt das heißt
denken Sie doch an das Wunder von Bernd
zurück das waren doch Zeit
nein nein
das ist so eine Verlängerung meines
Lebens nach hinten hin aber
nein aber es ist aber man muss nicht man
das Wunder von Bernd denken ich denke
zum Beispiel ich wollte mich jetzt ich
bin also ein Union Fan und ähm
aufmachen
will ist das ist ein das ist ein Verein
der hat sich hochgespielt also
hochgespielt nicht im Sinne von Politik
sondern durch Fußball hochgespielt das
ist schon mal eine faszinierende
Geschichte im übrigen auch mit einer
Geschichte die bisschen die DDR zurück
reicht also man war schon ein wenig
Regime kritisch wenn man für Union war
und nicht für eine dynamo-mannschaft da
stand immer so die Stasi dahinter oder
Politiker ja aber aber es ging um den es
ging um um den Sport und es ging darum
dass diese Spieler in Spieler vorbild
waren und nicht weil sie politisches
Slogans oder weil sie
das gesagt haben was einige von ihnen
auch hören wollten und vielleicht muss
man auch einen kleinen Rückblick machen
und dann habt ihr alle schon erlebt und
zwar es gab ja auch eine Zeit lang in
der großen Koalition da sollte die
Nationalmannschaft nicht mehr
Nationalmannschaft heißen da überlegte
man ob sie nicht lamannschaft heißt und
ähm
ja wirklich und ähm und dann kam
wenn man sich das anschaut Vorbild Rolle
wir sehen den Beginn des Spiels und wir
sehen viele deutsche Spieler nicht die
Nationalhymne mitsingen
und wenn ich über Vorbild Rolle Rede
Bekenntnis zum Land wie man das Land
definiert ist ja auf eine zweite Frage
aber da geht es doch los ja das war das
Zeichen ist ja ihre Gesetze aber nein
ich meine nicht hier bei dem spiel ich
meine vorher schon Weltmeisterschaften
in Europa Meisterschaften sie können
sich die Bilder im Fernsehen angucken
sie können Sie in der Mediathek
hochladen sie werden sehen ich sehe ich
sehe eine französische Mannschaft der
italienische Mannschaft die begeistert
ihre Nationalhymne singen und ich
vermisse diese Begeisterung bei der
deutschen Mannschaft wenn sie denn
Vorbild sein will